I'm only interested in doing things that
we couldn't do on other shows okay you
know I mean have you taken off your
clothes on the program yes
yeah I've been naked okay yeah okay I
mean not full
oh god that's all ha skip this will stop
my sight see you guys in a bit
Oh God all right well let's do it it's
here let's do it
okay you've got sensei like hair running
nipples is that Asian sensei like the
guy who trains the people in the martial
arts I thought you're gonna play like
the bongos you can that's cuz that'll
definitely make the show I can't
possibly if you got to do it possibly
I can't possibly look for the outro
thanks so much for talking to his bench
warrant a little addictive
pillows